patrick invité exceptionnel entre et des
chroniqueurs exceptionnel alors quand je
t'ai exceptionnel bien sûr je lance tout
de suite le hashtag tristesse je suis
foutu hashtag solitude car ils vont
entrer c'est le retour du toc toc toc
vous connaissez le principe du toc toc
toc toc toc toc qui est là un prénom qui
correspond à une chanson de patrick puis
ensuite champ puis ensuite tristesse
puis ensuite bien sûr la personne va
s'asseoir et on l'entend plus jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission
attention vous pouvez voter chez vous
hashtag toc toc toc pour me dire qu'elle
est le toc toc toc préférées on va
démarrer tout de suite avec une personne
qui va taper à la porte
oui alors déjà le principe du toc toc
toc c'est de bien fermer la porte
merci merci donc on va leur faire mal et
jean-michel mai mais non mais non mais
qui dès qu'on me dit pas ton frère
c'est pas possible je lance ou dit le
hashtag re mal allez vas-y rohff et toc
toc toc qui est là c'est josé josé qui
faisait la voix
le sénat
bédard
[Applaudissements]
c'est la loi
c'est nul c'est nul c'est pas terrible
terrible c'est pas le mont mieux on a
fait mieux
patrick merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
serra
carcela quoi
les avis qui s'en vont et les autres qui
restent ce secteur pourra t on pas des
gens qu'on déteste et le temps qui se
perd reprenez musée des dieux qui espère
et ces flashs qui a dog à la télé chaque
jour
si on fait ça sur saxo
ceux qui sont avec nous ce soir là
chiche au bon beurre sur des tons chauds
maître chien là haut je suis là et toc
toc toc le prochain c'est le parti c'est
bon tu sais bien que tu es trop dit mais
je te dis quand même un moment j non
c'est parti ça c'est maghrib wales a
tiré au tir et etienne daho
on dirait etienne dans mais qu'est
devenu veuf on dirait etienne dans nos
messages
les visas les week-ends à juan
allez vous asseoir à beinheim merci m
remettez moelle mettez moi un peu celui
quand même jetés veille omettez voilà le
couple
on avait trop dit mais ce décor mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez répété avant mais pas du tout
alors s'il avait des répétitions la
suite aimé chose à sorède
allez on y va très partie alors il faut
que je dise qui est là alors si jamais
jean bernard ti jean bernard braun de
cette manne
[Rires]
à
jean
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pas des mouettes
oui mais qui aurait couché avec folie en
état c'est une cata merci allez allez
vous asseoir tard mettez la boîte c'est
le samu
c'est
nna
merci mais que vous l'équipe les ocf
touchante et on veut qui fait aller à
merde le prochain je suis pas fan basile
à quel moment j'ai été coiffée comme ça
dans ma carrière allait valider moyen
d'options de minutes oui mais parce que
je le vois le pauvre suis là depuis tout
à l'heure
frère théo thalasso et tu tournes études
renault ou à une caméra sur le gâteau
mausolée je vois un gars depuis tout à
l'heure il embrassera il aura deux trois
soleil il est comme ça bizarre de butare
où tu veux grèce là bas il ya d'autres
caméras de tout bouge pas et sortira
sera j'aime pas ça tout cas vous vous
cette petite coupe vous va très bien on
dirait david pujadas
oui c'est pas me dis allez vas-y et léo
et en tout et on s'était dit rendez vous
[Applaudissements]
là
voir
beau vainqueur
sur les
j'avais
[Musique]
à
la scène
et vous
[Applaudissements]
il ya juste la juste un gars qui cassent
l'ambiance
j'aurais handicapé rieur dirai pas le
prof de philo c'est vous suggère le prof
de philo alors avec moi 7 à 10 je peux
vous dire ça pas une telle angoisse
pourtant j'ai mis du temps à wade a
nommé non mais t'es plus dans mais
franchement c'est très angoissant à
merci mais n'y a aucun qui s'équipent
est beau gosse mais voûte façon vous
avouer voulu pécho toute la laponie
on va pas revenir là dessus ce sera le
19 décembre ce sera après une spéciale
verrez tout ce qui s'est passé en
laponie sachez chers téléspectateurs que
nous il n'ya eu un avant et un après
laponie ces quatre jours on laponie ont
changé beaucoup de choses surtout pour
une personne vous verrez ça pendant le
prime
on vous dit tout il va y avoir des
drames après la laponie on va pas se
mentir après ce train après ce prime
aura le 19 et le 20 il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont devoir quitter le pays et
vous verrez de crise il ya une salle en
laponie et du salon reid en salle alors
on va peut-être pour vous mais tout
était très propre
c'est à monaco qui a dû salle à monaco
du monde sont allés au tac
c'est comme un homme qui comme ça que
moi ça
parce que pour moi j'adore
[Applaudissements]
merci christine c'est que ça devait y
parvient c'est bien la perruque et la
tenue alors moi je n'ai chanter quelque
chose non non la chance à ceux qui nous
rejoignent
elle est sympa cette chanson je la
remets ta c'est vrai mais tu vois on l'a
on l'a oublié concert ensemble ajoute de
tout reprendre depuis le début la
chanteuse dit elle parce que alors
christine kelly en fait il ya eu un
épisode vos bonnes histoires on vous le
rappelle c'est qu'elle a fait l'émission
balances ton poste avec moi et elle est
partie un moment et on l'a entendu par
les roues christine je ne t'en veux pas
et donc c'est devenu un running gag
parce qu'en fait elle si oui il a tout
la parole 3 3 3 fois karim zéribi et moi
rien pendant une heure et demie je lever
le doigt
pendant une heure elle est là je ne sais
pas comment il s'appelle voilà voilà
diot avec 10 me mohamed ans s'est
rapproché nom vient du sal alors les
mecs là si je fais toutes les chansons
je vous le dis je ferai pas tout le
monde à les décevoir
ah oui oui non mais il faut dire sur le
facebook lite vous inquiétez pas c'est
parti à la prochaine c'est ma petite
préférée de l'équipe à votre avis de qui
il s'agit daniel bah oui à daniel motors
et daniel qu'il aimait tant
c
[Applaudissements]
daniel garcia lorca
là
[Musique]
celui de tomber les wampas côté là c'est
très émouvant pour moi de chanter
particulièrement cette chanson parce que
c'est la chanson qui a bercé mon enfance
ma maman m'a raconté que son premier
amour c'était sur cette chanson là mais
l'entente originale charentes et nord
voilà et patrick head on l'entend à la
musique soit tranquille a fait naître
chez suis là pour moi je pouvais pas
écrire la chanson j'étais à londres
l'hexagoal voyons pas pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent un petit peu d'histoire ne
fait pas de mal surtout pas surtout pas
vraiment en tout cas toutes les doigts
côté les brigades du tigre ne savons pas
très clair merci en tout cas vous
dossier des brigades de la l'humour on y
va aller là où la merde allez le
prochain alors qui
alors regarde
[Applaudissements]
google
arrêtez là tuez-le à tous pour ce faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec madeline wallonie le chevalier du
nerf sciatique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regarde je pense aux beaux yeux d'emma
série c'est vrai avec son association
aima on avec tours à fond et tu sais que
voilà je suis sûr que ça va aller de
mieux en mieux pour toi ma chien c'est
qu'on t'aime fort
[Applaudissements]
je suis allée la prochaine wii qui
stoppe comme ça c'est déjà on sait déjà
que c'est ça vient de dresser salaire du
tourisme donc quoi c'est qui
s'élargissent mardi rien que ça changera
sa maman alors oui laure services
s'élargissent
c'est la victime qui ne sait pas ce
qu'on a à l'ene a assez fait pas assez
de problèmes comme ça
bonsoir chefs cosaques à l'image de koné
le bus locaux de celle un dernier tac
toc toc de la soirée nazim mathieu on
dégoûte
alors alors si je suis en l'état parce
que maintenant c'est plus d'un an
ça suffit on n'y va pas partir alors toc
toc toc qui est aaa mais ça va saigner
yann rault merci
[Applaudissements]
il rappelé ces bons ne l'encouragé pas
je ressors pendant une heure
cyril tursan vont-ils avec tamara
guerrero n'ont rien à voir